okay so let's start class and start to
think about the
question how and why did the Iranian
president uh Ibraham Ry died okay so
um when you do history or you when you
do
analysis about current events you're
always going to have you're always going
to encounter three major problems okay
um the first major problem is that
there's very little
information that you can work with Okay
uh truth is very limited that's the
first
problem second problem is that um the
information that you
have may not be true
okay so there's also
misinformation that's the second problem
and the third problem is that there's
always going to be an official narrative
that the media the government
publishes and it may not be true but
it's the one that people people accept
okay
so um the challenge for us today
is we know that the Iranian primary
president Ibraham r basic
died and we will have to use analysis
okay Game Theory analysis to figure out
how he died and who might have killed
him does that make sense but the problem
again is we are working with very
limited
information that the Iranian government
chooses to disclose to the public okay
so what do we know we know that as a
fact that our on May
19th the Iranian president was in uh
Azan for a dam opening ceremony and then
he got into into his helicopter and he
was flying back into the
country and when he was flying back
there was an accident that caused the
helicopter to crash killing all nine
people on board including the president
the foreign
minister three crew
members um the governor of a province um
a local religious leader uh The
Bodyguard of the president and the head
of the president's security detail okay
so all nine people
died and we have reason to believe
that um the the most probable reason is
an accident
okay that this was an accident that it
was um bad weather there's a fog the
pilot couldn't really see any crashed
into the mountain and the evidence for
this is that um one this happens a lot
for example in 2020 the very famous uh
basketball player Kobe Bryant he died in
a helicopter crash along with his
daughter okay so this actually happens a
lot um the second piece of evidence is
that the helicopter they were
flying uh in is very old it was
basically an American
Helicopter that um they start to use in
the 70s and After the Revolution America
refused to cooperate with Iran so they
could never actually maintain the
helicopter so may maybe it was just a
malfunction okay um so these are two
compelling reasons why most people
believe this is an accident and this is
again probably uh the cost that will go
down in history okay but Game Theory
analysis requires us to explore other
possibilities so there are two other
possibilities second possibility is
foreign
adversary which means that either the
United States or Israel or even possibly
aan okay but a foreign
adversary um was responsible for this
the problem with this Theory though is
one of
opportunity and
motive okay so what this means
is it's very hard as a for government to
plan an
assassination of a Iranian leader in
Iraq right it's very hard the
opportunity isn't there so maybe Israel
America want him dead well how could
they pull it off it's very hard to to to
do such a thing
okay um second problem is
motive what reason would Israel or the
United States have for killing the
president now
in the past United States and Israel
have killed Iranians before so for
example in January
20120 president Donald Trump ordered the
assassination of General
salamani uh in Bagdad okay but there was
a motive here the motive is that
salamani is responsible for Iranian
foreign policy in the Middle East and
therefore a direct threat to American
interests okay and um Israel in the past
has staged
assassinations of Iranian nuclear
scientists in Iran but again the motive
is well Israel is afraid that Iran
develops a nuclear weapon and
therefore uh the easiest way to stop
that is to kill the scientist
okay um Israel
in a on April 1st of this year also
staged an air strike against the Iranian
Embassy in Damascus killing two Iranian
generals but again the motive is uh what
Israel said was that these generals um
were working with Hamas to threaten
Israel okay so the motive is very clear
and the problem here is it's very
unclear what the motive is for killing
the Iranian president okay uh um in fact
there's a lot of risk in that but again
I am not discounting the possibility it
could be a foreign adversary and the
third possibility
is an
internal
enemy okay meaning that there were
certain individuals or factions or
groups in Iran that wanted the president
dead okay and so with this eternal enemy
uh idea opportunity this problem doesn't
exist
because um obviously these enemies would
have resources to track down and kill
the president
okay um so an example of this is that
remember that when the president was
flying home he had in he had um there
were three helicopters right it was only
his helicopter that crashed the two
other helicopters were
fine now in theory and like we don't
know who was in the other two
helicopters but we can guess that they
were probably military escort right they
were there to protect the president but
at the same time if they wanted to kill
the president they
could
okay so was it the
military so the opportunity was there
but then the question then is is
motive why would they do that and the
answer is that um the possibility again
we are looking at possibilities
right everyone agreed that Ibraham
razy would most likely become supreme
leader of
Iran when the current Ayatollah
Ayatollah Kami
died okay so RI is
[Music]
63 um and CI is 85 so we can expect that
with within the next five years camani
will die and REI who many see as Chan
prodige will become the Ayatollah now
the um Iranian plugo system it's kind of
strange because it's an Islamic Islamic
Republic
and what that means is
that the ultimate Authority is God the
Quran and it's the Ayatollah who
represents uh the God and Quran okay so
he's the ultimate Authority he has
ultimate V veto power and the president
is maybe like the CEO of the country
okay so the PE the person with the real
power in the country is the Ayatollah
and if risi becomes the Ayatollah then
we can expect major policy shifts in the
country okay
um okay
so then the question then is okay well
who would benefit from R's death and
stopping him from becoming the next
Ayatollah and what people say is and
again guys uh I'm working with very
limited information I don't know Iran
that well I just read the news okay what
people say is that there are two top
contenders to be the next Ayatollah the
first Contender the most likely is Rey
the second Contender is actually Kam's
son um
mosta
Kami okay
so with him
gone mosta Ki is most likely to be the
next
Ayatollah now this presents a problem
for um Iran because it's an Islamic
Republic It's supposed to be under the
rule of God right and one thing that
most Iranian
oppose is the idea of hered hereditary
leadership okay a father passing on
leadership to his son because remember
that in 1979 the Iranians had a
revolution to overthrow the
king and everyone was was in favor of
over overthrowing the king okay so the
if Musta Kami did become AA this would
actually create a PO political
legitimacy crisis in
Iran okay and then the question then is
okay all
right so MOBA Kami benefits but who
would benefit from having him as
Ayatollah and the answer is actually
very simple um there's a group in Iran
called the
Islamic
revolutionary guard corpse okay or the
IR
GC okay uh we we will call them the re
Revolution
guards and what's interesting about them
is that they are separate from the Army
okay the
military so where do they where did
where do these guys come from and why
are they separate from the Army
what goes back to
1979 remember in
1979 there's a popular
Uprising against the Sha of Iran the
king of
Iran and the government brought back I
Iona Ki from exile to run the country
and Ki at that time was afraid of the
army because the Army had sworn
allegiance to the king so to deal with
this problem Ki established another
armed group called The Revolutionary
guard Corp okay and what they do is
actually very different from the
military the military has an obligation
to protect the
nation but the Revolutionary garor has a
responsibility to protect the revolution
the Islamic
Republic okay which means ultimately
that they are the Ki sorry they are K's
private
army they only obey
him and the other thing about uh the
revolution is that not only were they
trying to bring an Islamic Republic to
Iran but they were trying to export the
revolution across the Middle East okay
so basically the revolution garor had
two main functions the first m function
is to protect the AA and ensure the
revolution succeeds in Iran but the
other function is to export the
revolution to the Middle East okay to uh
spread uh Islamic revolution
to uh Syria Iraq and that's why the
Middle East were so Disturbed and so
angered by the
revolution all right now this was why
the irgc was
founded and because so many countries
considered Iran to be a threat they
encouraged Saddam Hussein to invade the
country in
1980 okay and this start something
called the Iran Iraq war and it was not
just um the Americans who support this
war War the Soviets also support sdam
Hussein and the Middle East countries
like Saudi
Arabia um um also supported Saddam
Hussein it was a brutal
war and a lot of Iranians died but
ultimately uh the Revolutionary guard
Corps were a was able to protect the
revolution from foreign Invaders and
because because of that they became the
most dominant military group
in um
Iran and so they almost had unlimited
access
to funds okay not only to protect the
revolution in Iran but also to export it
overseas okay so does this all make
sense to you guys but with so much
power they eventually became corrupt
right today um um people believe that
they control about 10 to 50% of the
entire Iranian
economy and because you have such a
monopoly of power it meant that um over
time the economy stagnated okay now
Western sanctions American sanctions
played a major role okay Iran couldn't
really sell its oil overseas but the
real problem was the fact that you had a
monopoly of power this revolutionary gar
Corp controlling the entire economy and
this led to protests okay so the first
group protest was in in 1999 you had
50,000 students protesting the lack of
democracy in Iran what they were really
protesting of course was the corruption
of the Revolution guard Corp but you
couldn't do that you can't say that so
they were protesting for uh
democracy they were crushed
then in 2009 to 2010 there's something
called the green movement and the idea
of the green movement was that people
wanted a new government that promised
reform and in election their candidate
the reform candidate lost and people
suspected that the Revolutionary guard
Corp um cheated and so there were
violent protest and again
the revolution guard suppressed the
revolution um and at that point
basically people lost faith in democracy
and so afterwards every other uh
president was basically a puppet of the
regime okay and most the most recent
protest that in
2023 there was a young woman named masah
ameni and she was arrested by the police
for failing to wear like head covering
in public and she died in custody okay
so people suspect that she was beaten by
the police and this caused massive
protests across the country okay so for
the past 10 20 years there have been
continuous
protests in Iran about uh the government
and the economy but mainly about the
fact that the
R goree has
monopolized the economy to its own
benefit which has caused the economy to
stagnate and for for people to become
poorer over time but because the protest
are so
widespread um the re Revolution guard
Corp ironically has become more powerful
because they are seen as the most loyal
to the current regime okay they're
loyalty is not um
contested and so what this means is this
what this means is that if is there if
there's a change in
leadership okay if the Ayatollah dies
and the new Ayatollah comes into Power
what the new Ayatollah will
do is reduce the power of the
Revolutionary gar
does that make sense to you guys because
he needs to establish his own power base
and the r guard core was loyal to the
current he's the the the r Gore is most
loyal to the current leader the ayatolla
kamani but if there's a new I comes to
power he needs to establish his own
power base so he he will bring his
people into power and that means
reducing the power of the of the ref
guard Corp okay does that make sense and
so there will be a direct threat to the
ref guard
Corp
now if but if the current Leader's son
mosta kamani were to become the new aola
then things would stay the same and the
reg gar would continue to control the
economy okay does that make sense you
guys all right so so again I'm
presenting a reason why the Islamic ref
guard Court would want to kill the
current
president um and ensure that the at's
son becomes the next leader because they
want to maintain the Monopoly of power
over the
country doesn't make sense to you guys
all right now I now want to
discuss who these people are and how
they think about the world okay because
um they're corrupt but they're
ultimately religious
Fanatics that want to export the
revolution across the Middle
East okay so let's talk about
1979 um in
1979 the Sha left Iran because there
were so many protest against him he the
shaw realized that um it was very hard
for him to stay in power despite the
brutality of the Army and the police
there's just too many protests too many
people want to see him gone okay so he
goes to
America and there are many Iranians who
are outraged by this for two reasons the
first reason is that they want the Sha
the king of Iran to stand trial for all
his human rights crimes while he was
uh king of of Iran okay that's the first
reason but the second reason is they
were afraid that the Sha had gone to
America to win America's
support
for uh a invasion of the country the Sha
was trying to get America to invade Iran
and put him back in power which which
happened in 1953 okay and so to counter
the threat of the Sha
in November of
1979 300 to 500 students college
students stormed the US Embassy and took
it over and held 53 Americans as
hostages okay and they demanded the Sha
be returned to Iran to stand
trial now um this is obviously an
invasion of American territory this goes
against international law but when the
stud did this there was so much public
support for the students that the
authorities didn't really do anything
also the Ayatollah Ki support the
students okay so there was widespread
public support for the
students when the students invaded the
embassy the first thing that diplomats
must do is basically destroy all the P
all all the files right all the secrets
so
um all embassies come with things called
shredders you you guys know what
shredders
are okay shredders are just basically
machines and if you want to destroy
paperwork very quickly you put in the
machine and the ma and the Machine will
cut the paper into about 100 different
strips of paper okay and this is the
fastest most effective way to destroy
your
documents and there are about like tens
of thousands of
Pages can you guess what the students
did over months the students
slowly and
methodically P the documents back
together one by one and what these
documents revealed to the students and
to the public in Iran is
that the real Center of power in Iran
was not the palace where the shaw lived
but the US Embassy it was the US Embassy
that was directing policy in Iran it was
the US Embassy that was responsible for
the brutality of the
regime and it was the US Embassy that in
1953 stag a couet against the
democratically elected government of
Iran and installed the police state of
the
shaw okay so these
students um when they read these
documents were really angry okay and you
can imagine that these students because
they piece together these documents
right the're
Fanatics and guess what guys these
students have gone on to become the top
military
leaders of the country
okay and I'll just give you three names
um Hussein Dagan who was the Minister of
Defense from 2013 to 2017 okay he was a
student protester in the US
Embassy that's one person second person
is Muhammad Ali Jafari who is not who
from
207 to 2019 was head of the Revolution
guard Corp
okay and and also Muhammad bagari who is
still the chief of staff of the Iranian
Army so the religious Gore are staff by
individuals who hate America and see
America as a great Satan and they
basically want to go to war uh with
America to avenge the wrongs and evils
that America did to Iran okay does that
make sense
second thing I'll mention is
that when when Sam Hussein
invaded um Iran in
1980 Iran didn't really have an Army and
the reason why is that uh the r guard
Corps had arrested or exiled or executed
the officers of the military because
they were not seen as loyal to the
revolution they were seen as loyal to
the Sha okay
so
um Iran didn't have an army and S
Hussein had airplanes he had tanks he
had lots of
soldiers and everyone thought that the
war would end very
quickly but then what the Revolutionary
G guard Court did was they organized a
new Army called the Basi
okay the basashi and this was a
volunteer army of poor religious people
from The
Villages and what the AL Alat Kini said
to them is we don't have
weapons but we have God on our
side okay the Iraqis have armor but we
have divine power and what they did was
um for to these villagers and and these
guys are about your age okay they're 16
18 and they gave each of these
guys a rifle and a key to put over uh
their necks okay and the idea is that
this key is your entry into heaven
because when you die in war you are
granted automatic automatic entry into
heaven and so these guys and they were
organized into groups of like 22 okay
okay they would run ahead across Iraqi
minefields tanks would uh strike at them
okay hel helicopters would come and
strike at them and they would keep on
running and of
course um they would die okay
because um they didn't have any
armor but the Iraqis spent so much
ammunition and bombs
on
them that eventually the Iraqi Army
became exhausted okay does that make
sense and so they they
withdrew but then Iran took the fight to
to Iraq but this shows you that um the
main power in Iran why Iran is such a
powerful military is that their R guard
Corp are run by
Fanatics with a passion for uh
Revolution and they're supported by the
Bazi who are these poor illiterate
religious volunteers and there's tens of
millions of them for Iran to draw
on
okay
and um what the reg gar Corp has been
doing after the Iran Iraq war is they
they recognize that if an enemy comes
attacks
Iran people are going to
die um so they want to take the fight to
them okay and that's why for the past 20
30 years the re R gar Corp has been
supporting um conflict in the Middle
East okay they start something call the
axis of resistance
um so the active resistance
includes uh Hamas in the Gaza Strip
hesah in Lebanon the hufi in
Yan uh Syria the Assad regime in Syria
um as as well as Shia militia in um Iraq
okay and so all the money that the Russ
G Corp makes
in Iran is then sent to this AIS of
resistance to create conflict against
Saudi Arabia United States and Israel
okay does that make sense but so you can
imagine that there's some people and
there are actually a lot of people in
Iran who are like why are we doing this
again what what if we withdrew from the
Middle East and just f Fus on our own
economy then Israel Saudi Arabia and
United States would have a reason to
attack
us okay so there are people who who are
thinking like maybe the problem isn't
Israel maybe the problem isn't United
States maybe the problem is these guys
because they're Fanatics and they're
creating all these problems in the
Middle East which is crippling our
economy if we stop these conflicts and
just focus on our own e Economic
Development then maybe our people will
be better off
okay and one reason to think that there
are people in um Iran politicians in
Iran who are extremely skeptical
of uh ref guard policy in the Middle
East is that um in Jan 2020 in January
2020 remember that General salaman was
assassinated by the Americans right the
Iranian
response wasn't that big of a deal okay
the Iranians basically didn't
respond whereas the ref Gore because
their leader was killed they
demanded Vengeance right they wanted to
go to war but but we can suspect that it
was a politicians like
rayy who basically said no guys let's be
patient okay going to war against Israel
United States right now is
suicidal so they were urging caution and
restraint and the r guard Court didn't
like
that and then in and then April 1st of
this year they surely struck the Iranian
Embassy right which made matters worse
and again at that time I'm sure the re
ref G Court was let's just go to war and
again I'm sure rayi and his team said to
them guys we cannot beat the United
States and Israel in a war let's be
strategic about this let's be patient
our time will come but we need to be
patient
okay and uh I'm sure that because
they're Fanatics they were like they are
in our way these politicians are cowards
they're weak they're soft they're not
Believers let's get rid of them okay and
then what happened on May 19th was an
opportunity arised where there was fog
and they were like well here's
opportunity and so they caus an
accident
okay does it make sense
guys all right so again I don't know
what happened but if we look at Game
Theory and we examine who would benefit
from the death of
REI this group of people the r gar Corp
would most benefit because it is very
likely that if REI became next supreme
leader their Authority and their
policies would be
challenged
okay and so by getting rid of
RI it makes maaba kamani the son of the
atah that much more uh probable in
ascending to the supreme authority and
that allows them to maintain their power
Monopoly of
power and even if this assession causes
a legitimacy
crisis well it's good for them because
then the regime is even more dependent
on them okay does that make sense so
during these protests as
um the especially the green movement the
Rel Gore was was the ones responsible
for cracking down and they were violent
and brutal in cracking down
okay
so okay um are you guys
clear about the logic here any questions
okay that's um great question so s asks
does the military still exist and the
answer is yes it still it still exists
okay but
again um the res G Corp has certain
responsibilities that make it the most
powerful group okay so the first thing
is that um it's responsible for the Navy
okay why is this important because the
straight of homus is a very strategic
shipping Lane and because and so they're
responsible to maintain that straight
okay and the Navy allows them also to
smuggle which means that they can make
more money for themselves okay so that's
the first thing second thing is that
they're also responsible for the uh
missile
program the missile program okay and
this is where actually the military
spends most of its money the missiles
Okay the third thing thing uh is of
course uh foreign
policy meaning that the act of
resistance gets in sorry the AIS of
resistance owner interacts with the
resue G Corp okay so uh General salaman
and the two generals who
died uh in the Israeli air strike they
all belong to the Islamic revolution G
Corp okay so these three things uh mean
that the um Islamic revolution guard
Corp they control basically all the
money and all the power in the
country okay but they're still
military does that make sense all right
any more
questions okay so Jack asked a great
question why is the reg gar why do they
believe that they can control Marhaba
kamani okay okay so um in
1989 the first Ayatollah Ki
died and aah Kami succeeded him and the
moment he became the new Ayatollah he
focused on cultivating his personal
relationship with the res guard Corp
okay so basically he know there's about
2 ,000 of
them and he made a point of meeting
everyone and memorizing their names even
knows the names of of their
children so the current Ayatollah kamani
has a great personal relationship with
the Islamic repr G Corp okay they're
basically his private
Army
and the reason why that the ref ref gar
would transfer loyal to musaba is that
mhab himself is an extremely unpopular
figure if he were popular if he were
like a clever politician then he would
most then he would most likely become
next
Ayatollah but because he's he's very
unpopular um there's a lot of resistance
to him so if he becomes next Ayatollah
it it would be only because the rary GP
put him there which means that he must
be loyal and obedient
to their policies does that make sense
Jack okay but that's a great question
any more questions before I move
on okay so Seline asked a great question
what changes now that re is dead okay
now all right so
if it was an
accident then in theory nothing changes
because ultimately it's the a Ki who is
responsible for
policy okay but if I am correct and I
and it's the it was a plan assassination
uh by the res GARP then everything
changes okay what this means is
that um the political class goes away
and the military class takes over and
they dictate they dictate
policy okay so you will
see um first of all um there's going to
be a a election okay so in late June
there will be someone to replace the
president and it's most likely that the
current vice president who is Muhammad M
mbar the current vice president will
become the new president and this is
important because rayy does not come
come from the rest guard Corp he comes
from the Judiciary okay that's a
different Power base but Muhammad marbar
comes from the ref gar Corp so he would
Advance ref gar Corp
interest okay and if that's the case
then what what we'll see is um the
country the leadership preparing its
people for total
War okay we will see that the rhetoric
becomes more
extreme and preparing its people for an
eventual American
Invasion there'll be much more harsh
crack down on political
descent
okay um so that's the first thing second
thing is that the res GARP cannot defeat
America face to face okay the only thing
that they can do to defeat America and
Israel is to lure them into the
country and they do that by provoking
them okay so there are different things
that they can do to provoke America the
first is
to
accelerate the nuclear program
okay what America and Israel have said
is they see Iran possessing nuclear
nuclear weapon as an exponential threat
to the safety of Israel
so this is a no no okay so if Iran
accelerates the program this this is a
direct Pro provocation okay that's the
first thing second thing is
to encourage the
proxies okay so right now Israel is very
concerned about hesah in the north Hamas
has has already attacked
them hesah could also attack Israel if
hesah attacks Israel then Israel can
only interpret this as Iran encouraging
Hezbollah to attack
them okay but if Hezbollah attacks
Israel then Israel in the United States
would see this as an escalation and they
would be much more determined to
eventually attack Iran in some in some
way you also
have um Shia militias in in Iraq who
could attack US military
bases okay you also have the hoovies in
y man who can attack Saudi Arabia oil
fields okay so you're encouraging your
proxies to make things worse in the
Middle East in which case United States
can only conclude that we need to
destroy the head of the snake which is
Iran okay the second thing that that
could happen the third thing that could
happen
is uh
um
basically Iran starts to attack shipping
lanes okay it makes shipping much more
difficult okay and the fourth thing
is basically Terror basically um Iran
through its proxy launches Terror
attacks against America and its
allies okay so there are many things
that Iran can do to provoke a
war and again if I'm right and I don't
and again I don't know if I'm right or
not then we should expect that in late
June Muhammad marur wins the election
and his rhetoric becomes much more
extremist we need to take the fight to
America okay we need we need to avenge
solomani we can also expect that the in
the midal ease becomes much more
extreme
okay and we we should see
escalation um the acceleration of the
nuclear
program um proxies become much more
violent uh shipping is is um Disturbed
and you have a terror campaign uh
throughout the world okay does that make
sense all right but again I don't know
um and also by the way just because
these things might happen does not mean
that RI was killed by the r gar Corp
okay do you understand but I'm saying
that um if in fact the r g Corp did Kill
Ry then we should see these things
happening but just because these things
happen does not mean that uh REI was
killed okay does that make
sense all right
any more
questions um okay so seline's question
is how would they fight the war and they
can only F the war in one way which is
to lure the Americans into attacking
Iran okay does it make sense it is
suicide to attack America in the open
remember that America shuing all which
means that they have ear suy which means
have satellites that can see everything
that you do which means have special
forces okay it is suicide to attack
America uh in the open so what Iran
needs to do is Trick America into
invading
Iran and then America would lose for
sure okay and that's something that
we'll discuss next week but that but
that's what they have to do and again if
they provoke America enough then America
will eventually get get angry enough to
send an invas Force against Iran does
that make sense okay any more
questions is this clear is this clear to
you guys the logic here
okay so um again this is all speculation
I have no actual information or evidence
okay I'm just saying okay rayi died and
it was probably an accident but if it
was not an accident then who would most
benefit from killing him or his death
and the answer is the re the re
revolutionary guard core because they
see him as a direct threat to their
Authority okay but at the same time
what's important to remember is that any
new leader would see these guys as a
problem because they have too much power
and they are creating too much tension
overseas and they're too fanatical okay
and so
um uh it's most likely that they would
want to elevate mosab kamani because
mosab kamani is not popular and he would
have to be loyal to the rever gar Corp
or he would need their help to maintain
power okay but I okay does that make
sense guys all right so next class we'll
discuss what an actual war between
States and Iran would look like and
what's important to remember is that
I've been saying all semester that
United States will lose the war but
never have I said that Iran will win the
war okay and the reason why is that this
war will be brutal for Iran tens of
millions of people will die for no
reason and that's why politics like Ry
and others are like let's not go to war
okay all right so I'll see you guys uh
next week